we also had a debate on the single
market strategy for goods and services
which is a new roadmap for reducing in a
targeted way the obstacles that
companies and consumers have to face on
the market in particular geo blockage
the council has called upon the
Commission to table ambitious proposals
to allow enterprise and consumers to
avail themselves of all the
opportunities of the internal market we
also took stock of the situation
regarding polluting emissions from cars
the follow-up to the Volkswagen affair
in this context we also looked at the
adoption of the regulation on real
driving emissions tests the new
regulatory framework which we've just
decided upon is also a first important
step in reducing polluting emissions we
discussed better regulation the
discussion showed that there is a
consensus on the need to make our rules
simpler more transparent and more
effective I presented the second
competitiveness checkup with the focus
on the on the international
competitiveness and the EU's comparative
advantages it is very important to say
that Europe is really still successful
competitor worldwide and of course our
comparative advantages I in our capacity
to deliver high-quality products across
a broad range of sectors and markets I'm
happy and proud to say that we have
adopted to date three sets of
conclusions covering our priorities
research integrity furthering gender
equality in the European research area
and review of the European research area
advisory structure would collapse he has
an exchange of views on the EF as I
European fund for strategic investment
based on and
sting in strategic projects in Europe
and making sure that the money goes to
the real economy liquid memorial if our
objective is to be in a world that by
definition will have open data and open
access research integrity is crucial